do I have to spray this man just a
thought that comes into my head so many
times daily you'd be surprised
[Music]
I'm Nate and I'm destiny how many dates
have we been on in life yeah what do you
define as a date I think like us going
out and doing an activity together I'd
probably say like like probably like 50
then yeah something like that
Wow maybe a date dates maybe like twenty
five dates
maybe less honestly now I'm thinking
about it
probably 15 I'm only gonna drink when
you drink how do you ask someone out on
a date
I personally ask them out very directly
I say hey you seem really nice I'd like
to get to know you more are you
available at this time for this activity
Wow yeah cuz then it's like is it yes or
no
that's for you yeah you know not a lot
of men do that anymore nowadays they
learn that the hard way I'm just like
that's probably the best yeah yeah what
about you how do you ask somebody out on
the date I don't you don't what do you
do if you like somebody you just send
vibes out I just see a sign right so I
hope that they ask me you just radiate
attraction oh I'm mad maybe I should be
more direct Wow what is your ideal first
date that's tough I feel like it really
depends on the person but I think that
like for me I love like a drink or
something quick because dinner is too
long yes if things aren't well I'm the
same I like something that's a little
bit more on the small end we're like
we'll great like coffee in like an
outdoor cafe oh we're like meet up at
like a park real quick but something
that has the potential is so like I can
bail if I go yeah I want to get out of
here or if it's going well I'm like hey
do you want to grab some lunch right
turn into food
I like that but I like that baile factor
I like to know I can escape thing
totally I'm so bailed you can always
tell within like the first like minute
or two you like this is gonna go well
and then sometimes you're like mm this
is gonna suck
what's your grooming routine uh my
grooming routine mine's probably the
same for my daily life I probably like
just pick it up a little bit extra but
like just like shower shave brush my
hair I have dry shampoo now I do that
now it's pretty much the same I might do
a little bit extra makeup or like an
extra touch of something curl my hair a
little more I feel like a lot of women
have a tendency to like shave our legs
even though it's like no one's touching
my legs it's like probably don't have to
do that it doesn't take me long to get
ready but I end up taking a long time to
get ready as I'll be ready and I'm like
I'm good to go
and then I look in the mirror and I'm
like mm-hmm but do I like this shirt
yeah Sam I think it takes me longer not
because I'm doing anything different but
because I'm like nervous I'm like
stopping a lot to be like okay what
should I say or like how should we like
looking again but it's a lot of like
reef fixing or like what shoes versus
like mixing you matching mixing and
matching all that are you bringing
anything to defend yourself in case of a
certain situation
I eat pepper spray yeah I've never been
in a situation where I've been
physically threatened and I don't know I
think that's like less common with guys
yeah how pleasant it must be to be a man
sorry I ever spray I have a knife I have
a Taser you're nice I have everything
you been on dates where I've had to pull
both out oh yeah like knife in one hand
taser in their hand ready I've never had
anyone like in public try to do anything
so it's like that's fine but I always
carry
now I don't wanna drink cuz you're gonna
drink every time I drink we're just in
this together what's your ideal arrival
time ooh
I'm usually a little early just like
it's got the place out look for my exit
look parking like all that kind of stuff
so maybe like ten minutes earlier but I
grabbed the table or like whatever I am
comically early to everything I do
so I usually get there like sometimes
way too early and then I have to like
sit or hide in my car and then yeah then
come and like I just got here right yeah
I've done that before what is
appropriate to eat on a date you know
some women I've heard women like totally
like never want to see a guy again
because of what he ordered at a bar like
order to eat and I'm like I don't get
that
he's a kid he ordered chicken fingers
and I'm like I don't care what you eat
really it's about how you eat it he's
got like ranch olive yeah and I've been
on dates like that where I'm like are
you trying to eat the plate you're like
what's going on but when I'm on dates I
mean and maybe this is very
old-fashioned how touch women get a
light a salad I usually get something
kind of light just because like mama
loves some chicken wings but like I'm
not trying to be on a date sucking on a
bone and like really going to town so on
a date especially the first date I try
to be dainty I love that it's just like
tell me about yourself I tend to match
so like oh I'll let whoever I'm going
out with order first and then I'll go
off of so like if they get a salad I'll
try and get a salad yeah just cuz like
if I feel like I'm getting this like big
a little burger and they got like a
salad I'm just sitting there just like
yeah what do you like to do for fun
and I just look like a fool yeah but
what if you hadn't wanted that burger I
suffer I suffer for the day good man
more like on the way home I'll go
through the traffic what conversations
should be avoided
yeah I always play it by ear like if
there's something they want to talk
about and it's not just like let me tell
you about my ex-boyfriend oh then it's
like okay I'll listen like I've had
first dates we're like they wanted to
talk about their family okay I've had
first dates where they want to bring up
politics it's sometimes like a thing
were they like yeah this is something
that's important to me and I have to
tell you now cuz it's that important
okay honestly that's fair yeah I most of
the people I feel like that I agreed to
go on a date with I think however we met
or rather we were chatting prior we kind
of touch on some of those topics a
little before we can get to the date
because some of those things are really
yeah and I'm like it's not gonna work
but if you know you don't get that far
before you actually go out I as long as
you're mature about it I don't think
that like religion politics other social
aspects I don't think they should be
taboo like I think there's a way to
touch on it and if you see it going left
then be like got it like I understand
weird very different you know yeah who's
paying for the date it depends if I had
like a pretty decent time or if it's
like somebody that I'm like you know
what I had a nice time even if I don't
have a romantic connection at the end of
it right I'm just gonna pay for
convenience sake but if it's like
additional times like if I see them
again or if we've been going out for a
while
I'm not gonna automatically try and pay
each and every time so the first one's
on you the rest yeah the first one's on
me if it's like a really bad time and I
haven't like escaped in a cloud of smoke
yet then I'm gonna just sit there and
the checks gonna be there and it's gonna
be like yeah we should split this huh
yeah someone told me and I don't know if
this is a thing for all men or like for
whom but some men said that like they
get offended when women offer because
it's like a man herd thing so now I just
think that quietly and I wait cuz I'm
like I want to offend someone by being
like I have money
not any dude that gets offended that
you're trying to pay for his food or his
drink as an insecure guy he's like how
dare you give me money right I mean I
don't mind being but I think I like when
the guy pays
first date at least like it's kind of
nice it's like oh like gifts that is my
lovely
[Music]
how do you let you date down if you're
not feeling them oh I've had to do this
many times many many many times the best
way I do it is I just like keep saying
like I had such a good time like but I
really got to go to bed or I don't like
to lie but I'm always like I have to get
up early in the morning like that's like
my go-to if I say that you know I'm not
going to hang out with you I personally
really don't like ghosting it's like a
huge pet peeve of mine what happens to
me and I don't like to do it like like
even like a non romantic way like if a
friend calls me
I gotta count like I call him back oh
you're such a good person I try I'd be
like ah but not if it just didn't go
well and then they come back after me
and they're like yo hey that was really
fun I like that a lot I'd like to see
you again I'm just I know that was nice
it was cool to meet you
not really interested in doing that
again so you just say that yeah how do I
do that
teach me so what you do is you say hey
ya know I didn't really like that hey ya
know will there be a kiss at the end
that depends who even sometimes if I
really had a good time
I still might not try and kiss them um
I'm very slow about it I feel like when
I first was in the dating game I was
like I'm on game we can do whatever you
want but like now I'm kind of like like
I'm just I'm moving off slower these
days it's like you know like even if I
want to kiss that person cuz I mean I've
been on dates or I'm like romantically
attracted was like I'd love to kiss her
I'm like look at those lips but like
even at the end the date I'm just like
no maybe one more date like let me you
know I learned from Nate that it's best
to be honest and direct like yeah we all
say ghosting as mean and it is but we
all do it
that's you often but just be upfront and
honest if you're not feeling someone and
they're clearly feeling you don't waste
their time they put themselves out there
and have the decency of saying you know
what you're a great guy you're somebody
else's husband you're not mine
and just put it like like that I do like
that cheers today to Eddie
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you